hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcast I own mobility
mass spectrometry from metabolomics and
clinical research analysis presented by
dr. Richard Yost Colonel Allen R and
Margaret G Crowe professor and head
analytical chemistry University of
Florida director NIH southeast Center
for integrated metabolomics I am Alexis
Carlos of lappers and I'll be your
moderator for today's event today's
educational web seminar is brought to
you by laberd's and sponsored by Agilent
now let's get started before we begin I
would like to remind everyone that this
event is interactive we encourage you to
participate by submitting as many
questions as you want at any time you
want during the presentation to do so
simply type them into the ask a question
and click on the send button well answer
as many questions as we have time for at
the end of the presentation also please
notice that you will be viewing the
presentation in the slide window to
enlarge the window click on the arrows
at the top right hand corner of the
slide window if you have trouble seeing
or hearing the presentation please click
on the support tab found at the top
right of the presentation window or
report your problem by clicking the
answer question box located on the far
left of your screen this presentation is
educational and thus offers continuing
education credits please click on the
continuing education credits tab located
at the top right at the presentation
window and follow the process to obtain
your credits I'd like to now introduce
our presenter dr. Richard Yoast dr.
Richard Gauss is the colonel Allen R and
Margaret G Crowe professor and head of
analytical chemistry at the University
of Florida he is recognized
internationally as a leader in the field
of analytical chemistry particularly
tandem mass spectrometry he may be best
known for inventing the triple
quadrupole mass spectrometer which 40
years later represents over 1 billion
dollars in sales each year dr. Yost
professional activities have focused on
research and teaching an analytical mass
spectrometry particularly tandem mass
spectrometry he currently serves as the
VP for programs of a SMS
we'll become president in July for a
complete biography on dr. Yost please
click on the speaker biography tab at
the top of your screen
dr. Yost you may now begin your
presentation well good morning everyone
or good afternoon depending on when
you're listening to this and I'm glad to
have a chance to share with you some
information about the research we're
doing in the area of metabolomics and
the use of high mobility in that space
so um so let's start out with a title
slide first everything you already know
what we're going to talk about today and
a little information about myself and so
one of my topics today first let's do
some acknowledgments this is my research
group of the University of Florida
currently I'm in front of the new
chemistry building and at the left side
you see the folks who have funded the
research that we're talking about today
so both these deserve acknowledgments
for the support they've given us and for
all the hard work the students do in
order to produce the science I'll show
you today so my topics first time I'll
give you some perspective on metabolomic
sand where mass spectrometry fits in I'm
going to talk about I'm a bit early
spectrometry and things and some
concepts on those to make sure that um
if you understand the basics of what I'm
there I'll then focus on talking about
eye mobility spectrometry with mass spec
for separating isomeric compounds and
we'll talk about steroids we're talking
about vitamin D and it's epimers and
then I'm gonna switch over and talk
about themes what I call selected
mobility monitoring or talk a bit about
strategies for improving things
performance the potential for a
point-of-care stand-alone fames and give
you just a brief idea of how it might be
used for drug analysis and then then
we'll come back with in summarize and
trying to do some perspective so box met
Olympics and Israel and its position and
the
world and you think about kind of
chemical biology and and and the omics
we're all familiar with kind of this
cascade of information in biological
systems where we started with genomes
the genes of DNA encodes
what we inherited from our parents the
transcriptomics is that it's transcribed
in order to encode proteins we study the
methodology of proteomics and that's
where a dozen years ago before someone
coined the term metabolomics talking
about the small molecules that work in
the body that that do the organs and
organisms and that's kind of our focus
for today and the interesting thing
about metabolomic this closer to the
phenotype is closest to the what we are
or an organism is and it also reflects
the impacts of both the microbiome which
is increasingly important we've come to
appreciate as well as the effects of the
environment so the that's kind of our
what we're gonna focus on today and nih
has invested heavily in metabolomics
recently come to appreciate that
metabolomic may be the most important of
the omics in terms of understanding
human health and the salty center for
integrated Mutombo lummix see some that
i direct is focused in that area so
metabolomic is not new despite the fact
the term is only a few years old the
urine wheel that you see here was
published in 1506 and it talks about the
colors and the smells and the taste of
urine to diagnose disease kind of scary
these days but at the time that was the
body fluid that was available and using
the sensory skills that that was had of
color smell and taste we think about the
earliest metabolomic sounded more like
the term we think about the term
metabolites was first published in 98 I
would Bob Guthrie's development in 1963
of a bacterial inhibition test for PKU
phenylketonuria as an example of target
metabolomic son that was before as it's
commonly used in as Nana cortex
certainly is a medical technique but
that was looking for a very specific
targeted analyte we want to think about
untargeted metabolomics we might go nine
years later Pauling and I mean 72 would
you did a GC analysis of two hundred and
fifty different compounds in human
breath and kind of the perspective for
today today over four million
newborn screenings performed annually in
the United States all by LC ms/ms one
enormous impact on human health mass
spectrometry has and in metabolomic just
in that one area of screening so let's
talk a bit about why today we don't do
things like GC by itself we do things
like LC ms/ms what I would call
hyphenated analytical methods those are
the standard today's talk about that
concept of tandem or hyphenated methods
we're typically talking about doing
mixture analysis and we do this by
combined being in tandem memory
techniques might give us more stages of
analysis so here's kind of the concept
of what happens is we increase the
number of stages of analysis from one to
two to three to four on the signal and
the noise and the signal to noise so if
you think about it and we're just age of
analysis one stage of analysis here
might be GCE or LC or a mass
spectrometry any one of those by
themselves
I'll see a mass spec would be a good
example of a two stage method perhaps
the most common today may be GC mass
spec is even more common still and what
happens is we go from one stage to two
stages first note that we lose signal
inevitably putting a second mass
spectrometer in front of our first one
or a chromatographic column in front of
an L of a mass spec you lose
signal along the way there's not a
hundred percent efficient so why would
we do it so the reason we do it is
because it hopefully reduces the
chemical noise which ultimately limits
how low we can detect and identify
compounds and so if as you added more
stages of analysis from one to two and
so on if the chemical nose goes down
faster than the loss of signal and the
signal noise which determines detection
limits and how low we can identify
compounds improves and so if you look at
this graph you'd say well if few stages
of analysis is good three would be even
better and indeed we can do LC ms/ms at
very common nothing today the most
common clinical assay method done using
a triple quadrupole mass spectrometer
will be to adding a fourth stage when
would that be useful and that might
reduce chemical noise even further and
give us better signal to noise let's go
to even lower levels so that's gonna be
our topic today is role of ion mobility
spectrometry in LC mass spect primarily
we'll talk about it in some other
contexts as well so IMS is eye mobility
spectrometry kind of our topic for today
so if you're not familiar with eye
mobility spectrometry and the method
then very widely used um but that you
probably didn't or anything about back
in a chemistry class the classic way is
doing this with what's called a drift
tube so you have an ion source here feed
ions into a drift tube typically in a
pressure like an atmosphere maybe a
fraction of an atmosphere and the ions
have poured along by electric field is a
gas present as well and so what
determines how fast the ions move is
there a collisional size the physical
size small ions move more rapidly than
big ions so if you have a mass analyzer
or any kind of a detector back here at
the back as you that the small ions
arrive first and then over time the
middle size and the larger ions so it
separates things according to their size
so if you think about putting that
together in the middle of an LC mass
spect
particularly if the mass spec uses i'm a
flight of very fast mass spectrometer
give you a very ideal time scale
marriage give you a complete LLC I'm
ability mass spec data in real time
during their chromatographic Rutan so
think about a liquid chromatographic run
maybe on the order of 10 minutes long
and then at every point in time they're
big and I'm a bit of a spectrum because
that takes this a little less than 100
milliseconds to get the complete
mobility spec list it tells us the size
of those ions they were formed in the
ion source and then if we're using a
time-of-flight mass spectrometer
complete mass spectrum takes us maybe
100 microseconds so at every point in
drift time we also get him plate mass
spectrum so that's a remarkably powerful
way to get complete LC mobility mass
spectrometry data on that instrument so
a lot of the I'll show you today is on
an absolute 65 60 a an LLC mess back
instrument a LCQ top that has my
mobility spectrometer in okay so why
would anybody do this why put a mobility
spectrometry in the middle of an LC mass
spec instrument um first isn't it as an
additional separation stage you can
resolve compound classes that way um
reduce interferences and if you can
reduce interfere you could either go to
faster LLC separation or perhaps even
though the quick chromatography
separation in some applications you can
also use that to help identify unknowns
because now not only do you know
retention time and and mass you also
under something about the size of the
ion and therefore the size of the
compound something I'll show you
primarily today is the idea of using I'm
abilities now for you solve isomers that
have the same exact mass and may be very
difficult to separate by the
chromatography on let's talk about an
example of doing that let's talk about
using AI mobility spectrometry separate
isomeric steroids so here's an example
very familiar to many of you the four
membered for poor green system this is
Andres Tyrone and Andres Darren has
an epimer called transgender Cerrone and
the only difference between these two
molecules is that this carbon in one
case the hydroxyl group is behind the
ring and one case the hydroxyl group
comes out so this is an epimer chirality
changes are just that one carbon and
this can be very hard to separate
chromatographic they obviously not gonna
be separated by mass spectrometry they
have the same exact mass can we resolve
them by eye mobility so when you do that
experiment this is now looking at drift
time on the x-axis time around 25
milliseconds you can find an der starin
comes out if you vent and transgender
stir and separately
you see it's slightly larger comes out a
slightly longer drift time notice that
in this case we're looking at the m+
sodium ion these are made by
electrospray so be mass 313 then I
resolve that doesn't do much to help us
in separation but um you know as a
professor I always prompt my students
did you try this did you try that in
this case I said what if we look at
longer dif times than 25 milliseconds
what else do we see so this is that same
you just saw for an der starin and
transcender stern if you look out a
longitude of times you find these two
more Peaks one for under zero and one
for the trans compound and they're
totally resolved no problem at all so
those are dimers it turns out so one
sodium plus two molecules of either one
of the steroids and there's dramatic
differences in their sizes and there
were created by mobility an interesting
question of course is why would those
two dimers so da to dimers differ so
much in mobility and therefore in size
want to figure that out we can go do
some calculations so we turned our
quantum theorists friends and this is
the structure they get for the dimer of
andros Tyrone with one sodium ion it's
relatively compact and if you look at
the Trant
starin as well be patient the hydroxyl
this one will not sit together it's
coplanar and the larger size and because
it's larger size as the longer drift
time and is easily separated so that's
an interesting way to separate steroids
and we're using that currently in a
project funded by the world anti-doping
agency to look for Olympic they're
testing what if we think about more
clinically in isomers than the steroids
how about vitamin D so 25 hydroxy
vitamin d3 and d2 are probably the most
commonly analyzed clinical compounds
these days it depends upon how much
interest there is in the popular press
about being vitamin D deficient and here
we see the drift time for 2500 arc C
vitamin D 2 here in purple and d3 again
the Saudi ated ions of those and they're
somewhat resolved but it really doesn't
matter because they have very different
masses and therefore we can separate
them easily by mass spectrometry more
interesting me to us for these is that
both of these compounds that you want to
analyze for 25 hydroxy vitamin d3 and d2
but let's have that boomers just like I
showed you from steroids that is a spot
on one of the Rings where there's a
hydroxyl group that's either behind or
in front of the plane therefore
difference in chirality just one of
those carbons and here we can see the
epimers are somewhere resolved by as
they're so d ated ions but again what if
we look at longer drift time so here's
what we see
those first two peaks around 26 to 27
milliseconds we have time out here a
longer group times we find that 25
hydroxy vitamin d3 itself has a second
peak and the epimer doesn't have a peak
at all out there so what's that coming
from looking at the here we can see kind
of the drift times calculated the
collision cross-section
calculated by the by the
software in the in the instrument you
can kind of see a lot of your time
versus massive chart if you want to look
at those as well these collision
cross-section is too small for a dimer
eye and we would expect if there's a
dimer would be bigger than that but we
see the same behavior for 25 hydroxy be
2 so it's not just b3 so what is that
second peak so again after you scratch
your heads a little bit you can talk to
your theoretician friends and ask them
to do some molecular modeling and when
they do this is what we see so this is
25 hydroxy d3 gives you the two peaks
this first peak the smaller is a close
conformation where the two hydroxyl is
on vitamin D associated with the one
sodium ion and by wrapping around the
sodium on you get a smaller structure a
smaller drift on the second peak for v3
is an open conformation where the sodium
is associated with just one hydroxyl let
me know which one is by modeling and so
this case for 25 hydroxy d3 we see two
peaks but with n+ o diems just two
different confirmations we can also
calculate for instant energy between the
two why do we see both confirmations and
it turns out it's about a 2 kcal per
mole difference between the applause and
open conformation low enough energy we
see them both if we look on the other
hand at the it forms application - but
we don't see any open conformation that
peak is missing and if we do the
calculation it turns out it's about 8 K
Cal's per mole to go to the open
confirmation for the there just based on
the orientation of those hydroxyl groups
so we don't see the open conformation so
the cool thing then clinically is that
we can look at both the upper and 25
hydroxy t3 but by looking at the
shortage of time and ce3 all by itself
with no interference by looking out here
at the long and earth time at this open
conformation so these are reasonably
high concentrations in order to do the
preliminary experiments can we
discipline eclis relevant constants
patience so here we are at 18 anagrams
from mil that would be a very reasonable
concentration range to expect for a
clinical assay on we still for 25
hydroxy III seem to be closed and the
open confirmation and the ACMA is still
missing it's it's open conformation so
indeed we should have no problem to UM
to see both both of them even at low
concentrations then we quantitate 25
monography based upon this unique open
conformation peak here that has no
interference and so here you see a
calibration curve for doing that the
blue dots are collaborators we have
plasma our red squares are plasma QC
samples and our square ii point nine
nine nine four so so good linearity
precision one to five percent unlimited
five nanograms per mil
so certainly low enough to do the clinic
our assay this way and be able to
resolve the epimer from 25 b3 Caronia
said two minute LC separation
significantly faster than anybody else
can do this and still separate the
epimer our long-term goal is to do this
in ten seconds
obviously metric chromatography in that
time scale and use other ways that kind
of tandem hyphenated methods we've
talked about other ways in doing
something up in the front to complement
i mobility which is also cleaning up the
samples for us okay now i want it kind
of skiers i want to talk about different
kind of item ability i want to talk
about themes and first time you point
out why aims i think is interested I
think it's it's interesting I think it's
interesting for targeted analysis most
of us think about doing targeted
quantitation by LC ms/ms using a triple
quadrupole mass spec and monitoring
picking one parent iron ore precursor I
and
Fryman looking just one of its daughter
or product ions selected reaction
monitor why want to get across the
concept of selected mobility monitoring
what we just look
one mobility while we're looking at one
parent and daughter Ryan I think this is
very attractive for targeted
quantitation let's talk about that so
I'll see you again maybe you're not even
doing I'll see in this case but if you
are say 0 to 10 minutes and things take
no time it's pretty much instantaneously
you can pick a peak at a given mobility
here as you see and then when you do on
the back selected reaction monitoring
with the triple quad you're gonna pick
one parent going to one doctor so
basically at every point in time and
they come out a graphic ground you pick
one mobility one parent one daughter
very much a targeted analysis so now
let's talk a bit about how things work
so you have some appreciation of that so
here's kind of a classic image of a
drift 2 by a mobility spectrometer this
is the kind that's used at airports for
checking for explosives
so in comes your sample you ionize the
ions here trap them behind a grid and
then pulse them as a narrow pulse into a
drift tube and they drift down the way
as we talked about earlier the small
ones arrive first the bigger ones arrive
later they can arrived here either at a
the detector or go into a mass
spectrometer so that's IMS now let's
talk about what fames is all about so
fames we start out with ions ions source
as well move them between two electrodes
pair electrodes shown here and the gas
flow moves them along I'm like in the
top case where they were moving by an
electric field and we apply an electric
field between these two electrodes and
that makes these ions go up and down and
up and down let's talk a bit about the
concepts of how things differs from high
mobility spectrometry and how it's
similar
so first things is similar to
conventional drift to by mobility twice
typically operated atmospheric pressure
and a room temperature although
sometimes we vary either the fracture of
the temperature to optimize performance
though separate lines based upon their
mobility as they move through
gasps both use electric field can move
those ions through the gas but things is
different in many ways than conventional
drift to by mobility that we've talked
about up to now this I uses much higher
electric fields and this is the
fundamental difference why it behaves
differently typically on the range of
maybe 20,000 volts per centimeter versus
into drift to perhaps 200 volts per
centimeter so that's a hundred times
higher electric field and ions behave
very differently under that under that
height you lose I'll show you suddenly
the ions and move me magically to the
device if you think the previous picture
going to move from left to right not by
larger field by simply gas pushing them
through the electric field is applied
then orthogonal e2 that direction
perpendicular to that direction that the
ions moving to give advice that's
different than your tube um the electric
field is time varying it's not a
constant as in drift too but it's a it's
a wave form typically at a frequency
somewhere around and aggregates finally
fame separates against beam of ions
rather than pulse packets of ions so if
you think in a mass spectrometer for
analogy things device is kind of like a
quadrupole mass filter it passes ions of
a given mass in this case of a given
mobility um through continuously until
you change the settings where there's a
drift tube is more like a time-of-flight
mass spectrometer you start out with the
pulse of ions and the designs are
separated and then you put in another
pulse of AI and so it's discontinuous on
pulse packets of ions
okay so let's go back this fundamental
difference of what happens when we have
the luxury feel at the time very
electric field and I mobility and so
first let's think about what happens
with the electric field in general is
the drift velocity of anion we call that
B sub D therefore snow to the charger
where it's size that should make sense
if you double the charge of 9 and move
twice as fast an electric field if you
increase the size it moves more slowly
because then it goes more collisions and
it slows it down
so we can say the drift velocity is
proportional to the electric field and
that proportionality constant is K that
cave is called the mobility and if you
plotted velocity versus electric field
the slope of that plot would simply be
the mobility so we can indeed graph that
so here's I'm velocity on the y-axis
here is electric field on the x-axis and
the slope of that plot is the electric
or is the mobility K turns out that a
low field come hundred volts per
centimeter that behavior is linear you
double the ball teams thing I do twice
as fast you double the voyage agains
move twice as fast again as you might
expect from first principles but if we
go to high field is no longer linear and
let's look at that behavior so here's
kind of the night in fact at that high
electric field on K we got the high
field so here we're plotted out to ten
thousand volts per centimeter K becomes
a function of the electric field is also
compound dependent so why you'd expect
this to be linear behavior like that
dotted line when we go out to high
enough fields some ions become more
mobile than you'd expect they grow
faster then you would expect them to
when you increase the field those we
call type a ions will come back at Y in
a moment some ions go the other way as
you go to higher field they slow down
compared to what you'd expect them to be
and they deviate from that linear
behavior those are type C guards we can
plot - most people don't show this graph
because these differences are relatively
small from the linear behavior instead
they plot at this place you and see that
different they plot the change in K with
E so if you follow the linear behavior
they need this stir in behavior ions and
I'm one more mile as you go to high
field they deviate a positive direction
I pay the other ones negative types so
we can actually look at the electric
field that's used in this case and see
how that works so this is that ring
waveform is applied between the two
electrodes
it's the simply the sum of two signs one
or twice the frequency
the other and so when the two sine waves
interfere constructively high voltage
and when they're out of phase with one
another then they we need a low voltage
because they destructively interfere and
that goes back and forth so we alternate
between high field and low field and I
go to Mo Kio so if we go back to that
validity plot and think where we are at
the low field we're there any mode here
where this orange dot is and then half
an hour cycle later half a microsecond
or a microsecond later we now are that
high field where the green dots are and
now the mobility is is gone up or gone
down and that's the basis on which we
can separate ions at Highfield
so this alternation of this asymmetrical
waveform between high and low field
result time and therefore I in
temperatures which vary on that
microsecond timescale and so lots of
things can be on that microsecond
timescale the geometry of the ion the
stoichiometry whether you have monomers
or dimers inside plus training together
and this vine molecule their actions may
change and that may be the reason for
these differences in linear behavior
most low mass ions below a few hundred
mass units are type-a ions when you move
them fashion they become more mobile
most high mass ions are type C ions
type A ions presumably when they're
moving slowly they may be clustered may
be associated with other molecules and
when you speed them up they lose those
because of more internal energy type C
ions when they're moving slowly may have
a higher organ structure kind of be a
compact structure and when you move to
higher electric fields the extra energy
deposited into them by collision and
cause them to unfold not unfold like a
protein unfolds necessarily but in fold
just a little bit become bigger and they
become bigger they move more slowly and
so that's kind of the best explanation
we have for a in science so what's
happening to think cell here is let's
plot the applied wave form here so this
is one of those wave forms changing with
I've taken off an oscilloscope from one
of our instruments the dispersion
voltage difference between 0 and the I
field is the order of four thousand
volts into plus or minus then we have a
compensation voltage a DC offset on that
that I'll talk about it it's maybe as
much as I miss so we apply that to one
electrode is the other electrode
typically a ground start some gas flow
they're going through between the
electrodes make an I input a between it
as in them I believe that you would you
would see so this is an ion that it's
steep in the high field part moves that
far and the low field party doesn't move
quite back as far as being mobile and at
Highfield typing and so with every cycle
of RF it's moving a little bit towards
and one electrodes means place in this
case both the bottom electrode and if
you do three or four hour of cycles
maybe not too much happens but if you
have thousands of RF cycles that science
can get lost and go to the bottom
electrode did not make it through the
mass spec so this is net displacement
with each successive cycle the RF if you
start with different ions that have
different behaviors type a and type C
some ions to one electrode some to the
other and if you suck they're right some
of them will go down the middle and so
the way we pick which one of these ions
that we want to have come through to the
mass spectrometer is by bearing this
compensation boat is this
you see offset this CF or CB and we can
set that bias between these two
electrodes pick any one of the designs
and that it goes through to the mass
spec all the other ions are going to go
to the so the mast ions type a then to
go towards the bottom electrode here I'm
a science type C tend to move towards
the top electrode and we can set that
compensation voltage that offset to pass
one of those ions and that all the other
Ariens not be passed so it's a mobility
filter that compensation voltage is
compound specific you can pick a
compound you want to do on
and indeed as I in specific the M plus h
of an i and i plus a giant of a compound
may have a very different mobility than
the ax minus h- on the number of RF
cycles we use here varies a lot
depending upon the kind of theme so
we're using i'm use as few as 200 RF
cycles so that for 200 times some of
them use as many as 200,000 RF cycles so
if you use a many more cycles coming
through the device it's longer are you
running at higher frequency or the ions
are moving more slowly so you get more
cycles just as in a quadrupole mass
culture with mark our cycles you get
better resolution so you can very
resolution and also efficient somewhat
therefore by controlling that okay so
one of the cool things we observe them
several years ago now and we take
advantage but laden fames is the effect
of adding solvent vapor to fames don't
simply have the gas in that in the area
because there's electrodes be dry
nitrogen for instance but let's add some
solvent there
so here's four instances we're looking
at ortho phthalic acid the amount of h
minus sign of it on a planar cell gin
and as a compensation voltage where it
passes to a 17 boasts its peak width is
about 0.3 volts so that gives us a
resolving power of 45 pretty good that's
on the order of foremost drift to by
both instruments now if we add 14,000
ppm of isopropanol that's 1.4 percent
isopropanol on the into the gas into the
nitrogen now this compensation Bowlby's
jumps all the way out two hundred
seventy six volts ten times higher the
forward half max is still pretty darn
error and so the resolving power now is
about three hundred and so that's a
pretty remarkable resolving power for
things device ready my mobility was
moving get out of a grip to and it's
it's been done in a hundred microseconds
is the ions child do that that some
makes famous very interesting as
almost instantaneous separation device
that have very high resolving power by
using the interaction of with solvent
molecules as they pass through the thing
so I mean commercial instruments
oftentimes have meant that now today so
that's the fact I kind of summarized
this solvent vapor effects important
points one is that we get dramatic CV
ships if you saw in that last case that
improves the resolving power and the
peak via the separation it also
interested in certain pieces resolution
you can better separate isomers remove
the appearances things like that that
way it also interesting the increases
sensitivity to the device something
you've not expect to get both improved
separation resolution and sensitivity
case this all be Lyons the more massive
seems to survive much better going
through the device our interest in this
is partially that this makes this very
attractive as a device for breath
analysis since our human breath is
saturated with water vapor and water has
this solvent in fact yeah so um so
that's one of the areas that we have a
lot of interests so we've done a lot of
things applications we've use fames with
tandem aspects things like vitamin d and
steroids kind of in parallel but about
you stop with the drift tube Johnny
speaking the drift tube is very
attractive of these because you know
what's going on you can pick the
behavior but things as attractive as
being a smaller device that could be
used for targeted analysis we also
interested in famous as a standalone
device for a point of care clinical
device ultimately and for its ability to
do breath analysis based on the improved
performance of having water vapor
present along with the ions hmm one of
the things that we have in mind is using
fames with tannin mass spec for method
develop in the lab and also for
laboratory confirmation of data you
might take in a field of all stand-alone
things device um so we have a variety of
applications that we're looking at for
the breast side one is a breathalyzer
for THC
so four states where marijuana has been
legalized now you can it's legal to use
it but it's not legal to drive under the
influence much this it's not it may be
legal or is illegal to drive having to
drink alcohol is not go drive under the
influence so a breathalyzer for THC
would be one very attractive application
another one would be early screening or
routine screening for disease biomarkers
in the breath so I think standalone
famous is an awful lot of interest on
top of things combined with mass spec
but let me just wrap up by kind of
showing you an example of using this for
breath analysis
this is researched I definitely making a
breathalyzer for marijuana use we can't
do that on campus at the University and
you can't even smoke a cigarette on
campus so a student walks across off
campus across the street smokes a
cigarette comes back and squeeze into
the mass spectrometer here you see the
individual breaths
this is planar fames device dispersion
ball reach 4,000 volts set at a cv to
pass a particular set of ions three
graphs in one minutes this is 30 minutes
after you get the mass spectrum in that
peak and when you do that you see it
contains nicotine and cotinine and not
much else
so the thames has done a nice job of
cleaning even though we have no
chromatography here this is a real-time
analysis then you see th see the
compound you care about looking for in
order to help States monitor driving
under the influence
smoking marijuana cigarette or ingesting
it this happens to be a hemispherical
famous cell this particular spectrum so
this is THC M plus h this is a same
spectrum of compensation voltage and
here you see THC appears here amad when
I mount the Western did different things
value so yes that we may be able to view
that well enough and indeed here is a
calibration curve looking for
th see this hemispherical Thames del
log-log plots it's nice and linear and
based on Beck's work this would be the
level president breath after about two
hours after smoking cigarette and we can
easily get down to those levels so um so
that's an interesting future I think to
watch for or use is a breath analysis
device um you can also think about as I
mentioned before looking at biomarkers
this is a standalone
fames device looking at various VOCs
volatile organic compounds in the breath
related to liver cirrhosis um so here's
two pens known to be known endo and
depent known and in dull so positive and
negative mode and so it's interesting to
think about what we could do using this
as a Malone device or I'm screening for
this please let me try and give you a
summary then of the things we've talked
about today both gift availability and
fames as well as other ways of doing i
mobility like counting way by mobility
or captain mobility I think a very
promising for metabolomic center
clinical analysis
I'm ability put in the interest for
separating our samara compounds also
useful for cleaning up spectra for doing
LCM aspect i think fames is most
interesting to me as the selected
mobility monitoring device a targeted
device things like breath analysis the
potential for having point of care
stand-alone fames devices that we could
easily imagine would be the size of a
cell phone not the size of a mask our
Trump funny if you're interested in
learning more about this we published a
review in 2016 and I mobility
spectrometry and clinical analysis in
the journal Clinical chemistry so you
might want to look that up and and see
what the state of the art is in that
area so I'm finally let me thank you for
for your attention and see if there's
any questions thank you dr. Yost for
your informative presentation we will
now start the live Q&A
portion of the webinar if you have a
question you'd like to ask please do so
now just click on the ask a question box
located on the far left of your screen
and we'll answer as many questions as we
have time for so let's get started our
first question is in addition to drift
tube IMS and Thames
are there other ion mobility techniques
that could be useful in metabolomics and
clinical studies so our experience in
our laboratory has all been with you the
drift tube or Thames but there are two
other versions of I'm abilities that are
what someone is your drift tube then
themes that are commercially available
as well so one of those would be
traveling wave for mobility spectrometry
that's available from waters and trap
time ability which has recently been
introduced by Brooker classic drifting
by mobility available from Agilent and I
showed you at the beginning of the talk
here and fames is available from several
places thermo selves that SCI X and also
Alstom so most of things that I showed
you was on home built instruments here
but those have been commercialized as
well our next question is for separation
of vitamin D from its epimer you showed
that drip tube IMS would work how about
things we have been famous for
separating remedy from its epimer and
we've also and other people have done
that as well so I think that um man
that's certainly attractive as well most
of our work currently uses eye mobility
but um drift tube but I think this
promising as well doctor yesterday have
time for one more question
you showed that Saudi ated steroid
isomers can be resolved by IMS as their
dimeric ions
how about protein 'add protonated
steroids as would be formed by ATC I
okay so if you do electrospray for
for many stories you'll see protonated
as well as Saudi ated ions if you do a a
PCI you'll only see the protonated
species typically and generally speaking
the pair of native species do not give
good separation either they don't form
dimers like the Saudi eight and ones do
do that protonated theirs don't separate
and don't give you much self in size so
really speaking we find cat ionization
is better and so a lot of work in our
lab is dedicated to finding the best
cations for cat ionizing things to make
their mobility
give us better separation thank you
again dr. Yunus do you have any final
comments for our audience
urge everyone out there that high
mobility spectrometry can help them do
better analytical chemistry that are
metabolomics and better clinical
analysis and I think the good news is
there's a lot of commercial instruments
out there now that you can go try and
and see how helped you do either better
analysis or faster analysis and solve
cool problems before we go I'd like to
thank the audience for joining us today
and for their interesting questions
yes sir reminder any questions we did
not have time for today will be
addressed by the speaker via the contact
information that you provided at the
time of registration we would like to
thank laberd's and our sponsor Agilent
for underwriting today's educational
webcast this webcast can be viewed
on-demand through October of 2018 lab
rats will arive via email when it's
available for replay and we encourage
you to share that email with your
colleagues who may have missed today's
live event until next time goodbye